and then the middle one the one that
looks like the okay uh
finger or the triple six is gion mudra
and again many people are seen doing
this even in um Hindu dance you see a
lot of this and it's supposedly awakens
the crown chakra which is the snake
exactly so 666 snake wow see all
interrelated all and mudras what are
they it's sign language for the spirits
so you know they're they're nonverbal
modes of communication with deities each
finger represents a different element
and you'll see that they're into the
elements right well the same thing
happens in the occult right with the
pentagrams and the hexagrams and each
you know uh angle points to different
elements so when you start to make
different combinations with your fingers
you're invoking those energies which are
actually
spirits